[Music]  Jim whatever I do I do it to protect you  see I understand I understand  [Applause]  [Music]  our rebellion is all that remains to  push back the Empire I think he might be  able to help us when was the last time  you were in contact with your father  what is this  it appears he is critical to the  development of a super weapon  if my father built this thing we need to  find him all right how many do I need  they are requesting a call sign it some  rogue wrote one that we are dealing with  here  in measurable  if the Empire has this kind of power  what chance do we have  we have hope rebellions are built on  hope  I have no idea we're coming  the code of this moment the force is  strong  make 10 men feel like a hundred  take the next chance  and next  rebels on you  the dream  trusted without your shackles let's just  get this over with shall we  we've a mission for you a major weapons  testing